26TH.
IT WAS LIKE POST DATED
PERMISSION.
UNBELIEVABLE.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION,
FOX NEWS NATIONAL SECURITY
STRATEGIST DR. SEBASTIAN.
DAVID HAS NEGOTIATED EVERY ONE
OF MY CONTRACTS THAT I'VE EVER
HAD ON TV AND RADIO AND OTHER
BUSINESS.
AND WE ONCE BROKE BREAD TOGETHER
AND I PAID FOR IT.
ANYWAY, GOOD TO SEE YOU BOTH.
LET ME GO THROUGH THE TIMELINE
HERE.
PUT ASIDE THE -- I MEAN, IF YOU
LOOK AT THE TIMELINE, MANAFORT'S
HOME WAS RAIDED ON JULY 26TH.
THE MEMO DIDN'T COME OUT TO
CONFIRM MUELLER'S AUTHORITY
UNTIL AUGUST 2ND.
THAT MEANS BEFORE THEY RAIDED AT
DAWN WITH GUNS BLAZING,
MANAFORT'S HOME, THEY DIDN'T
HAVE PERMISSION OR MANDATE, AND
THEY GOT PERMISSION SPECIFICALLY
AFTER IT HAPPENED.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN, DAVID?
IT SOUNDS TO ME THIS IS DONE.
IT'S GOING TO BE THROWN OUT.
>> SOMETIMES JUDGES SPEAK FROM
THE BENCH AND FOOL PEOPLE, BUT I
THINK THIS WAS PRETTY
UNAMBIGUOUS.
THIS JUDGE IS IRRITATED, AND
RIGHTLY SO.
I HAD GIVEN THEM THE BENEFIT OF
THE DOUBT, BUT ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
THEY HAVE NOTHING ON TRUMP.
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
NO EVIDENCE OF OBSTRUCTION.
SO THEY'RE TRYING TO LURE HIM
INTO A PERJURY TRAP.
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET PEOPLE,
TANGENTIAL PEOPLE PRESSURED INTO
FLIPPING ON TRUMP.
BUT HERE'S WHAT IRONIC.
THIS WHOLE INVESTIGATION IS SET
UP ON THE PRETENSE OF PROTECTING
DEMOCRACY AND HERE WE HAVE AN
OUT OF CONTROL SPECIAL COUNSEL
IN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT EMBUED
WITH THESE PEOPLE.
THEY ARE TRYING TO OBSTRUCT WHAT
HE IS DOING AND ABUSING THEIR
AUTHORITY TO DO IT.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE JUDGE MEANT